(audience clapping)
- Thank you. Thank you.
So happy to be here, man.
- I like your corduroy number.
- Thanks, it's the season, right?
- I love corduroy. I know,
'cause it's so cold, right?
So wait, I think the last
time that we saw each other
was our "Drive Interview" that we did.
- [Wilmer] Yes, yes. Which
I had a great time with you.
Thank you for inviting me to do that.
- I loved it. But I loved your car most,
but since they came back on Netflix
with another "'70s Show", did
you have to give the car back?
Or did you get to keep it?
- You know, the answer is yes.
I rented it back to them.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- So I have the Vista Cruiser
from "That '70s Show".
- Yeah.
- That was the one thing I took
from the show after, you know.
- It's so cool.
- And yeah, so I took the Vista Cruiser,
which I'm hoping that when
my daughter's old enough to,
for me to take her to school,
that I can embarrass her
in that car, you know?
- Yes! Or be really cool.
- Oh, it'd be really great. Is that the?
You know, it's like the DeLorean
from "Back to the Future" for me.
- Exactly.
The flux capacitor, I wanted
one of those cars so badly.
So wait, you were also
Mirabel's father in "Encanto",
- [Wilmer] I was.
- Which literally still
plays in my household.
- Oh, thank you, yes.
- So since the last time
you were here, you did that
and I didn't get to talk to you about it.
So how was that? That
was such a cool movie.
- I mean, you know, working with Disney
is a dream, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You get to do these things
that, first and foremost,
to be a part of a movie that
meant so much to so many people
at a time where they
really needed that joy
was just different.
It was a very different type of movie too.
And it was a very different
type of movie for Walt Disney.
But it was the joy of my
life to be a part of that
and to be the 60th film
for the Walt Disney Animation Studios.
It was pretty iconic too.
- Wow, I didn't know that.
- So the whole thing was crazy.
I mean, even going to
the premiere, you know,
and seeing it all, you know, the colorful,
the red carpet and the whole thing.
And Kelly, the thing that I think about
when I think about that premiere
was being able to bring my mother
to that premiere for many reasons.
Because, you know, she's Colombian.
- Yeah.
- And the movie takes place
in a small little village in Colombia.
And for my mother, in her lifetime,
for her to be able to see, you know,
her Colombia portrayed on screen
as anything but what it's been,
you know, for decades and decades.
It was really, really beautiful. And then-
- Something she didn't get to see probably
as a child, you know?
- [Wilmer] For sure.
- Like, she didn't see
that when she was a kid.
- No, well, Columbia was
a very different country
when you saw it on film.
- But even like on screen,
like I don't feel like,
this is the first time
it's cool for my kids too,
to be introduced to a culture
that they don't know much about.
Like they're obsessed.
We have that freaking candle
lit in our house all the time.
Like we have, literally, they sent me
all this stuff from
"Encanto" and I swear to God
it looks like I'm obsessed
with Columbian culture.
- That's so cute.
- And yeah, I'm just like.
But they love it and it's a cool way
to introduce it to
people that aren't aware.
And it's also a cool way,
like representation, like-
- Yeah.
- Did you have anything
like that when you were
a kid to look up to?
Anybody that, you know?
- Yeah, I mean, I think
there's very few people that speak to you.
And specifically for
the Latinos, you know,
and back in film and television,
most of the characters that were portrayed
were unfortunately, not necessarily
who you wanted to grow up being, you know?
- Yeah, they were like typecast.
- Yeah, they were very typecast.
They were very stereotypical
characters, you know?
But when I look back, I look
at this one man, you know,
Desi Arnaz, right, who played
Ricky Ricardo, yeah.
- Oh my god, I was obsessed
with "I Love Lucy".
- Yeah, and I was obsessed too.
And you know, I used
to watch it in Spanish,
which was-
- I did not.
- A really, really funny.
I used to watch it in
Spanish back in Venezuela.
And I'll tell you something
that's really, really unique.
When I looked at him and
I saw him on this show,
he was speaking Spanish to
me as a child, you know?
And not until when I came
to the United States,
I realized, "Oh, they're
speaking English", you know.
But the point is that I
felt like I could be him.
- Yeah.
- And that I felt like
that was someone that sounded
like me, that looked like me.
And originally, you know,
he was speaking in Spanish,
so I was like, "Oh, anybody
can be that now, you know?"
And then you come to the United States
and you watch him do his
thing with an accent.
And so he was someone that inspired me,
not only as an artist, but
also as an entrepreneur
and as a producer and-
- Yeah.
- He's someone that done
so much for television.
I don't know if you guys knew,
but he created the multi-camera,
multi-cam format for sitcoms.
- You can watch the
documentary and find that out,
and the movie, there's
like two different things.
The documentary is just as cool as well
about the whole
- It's crazy cool, yeah.
- Yeah, I got my mother and
I just deep dove on Christmas
and just watched the whole thing.
We were like, "Oh my God!"
Like, 'cause I loved this show growing up.
Like most kids would wanna watch
something you're not supposed to watch.
I would go past my bedtime
'cause it'd come on at 10:30
p.m. to watch "I Love Lucy".
Like I, that's who I am.
- But what a magic combination.
When you think about
Lucy and Desi together.
Well, Ricky and Lucy, right?
- The chemistry, yeah.
- This chemistry, this
which was beyond culture back then.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It was beyond what
you looked like.
It was just an energy.
- [Kelly] It was so different.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I loved it.
So you guys have shot like
450 episodes of "NCIS".
Like what's it like to be a part
of such a magical crew and magical show?
- First of all, you know,
this is big shout out
and big hello to the crew
and every actor that share
the screen on that show.
I've only been on the show seven years.
The show's been on
- Only? (laughs)
- Well, I think I feel
like I'm always gonna
be the new guy because-
- It's been on for a long time, yeah.
- This is their, they're
going into their 21st season.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience clapping)
I love it.
- So they're doing 21 years,
right, it's like a long time.
But it has been a great joy in my career
to experience that, to be
able to be in people's homes
with a show that's so beloved
and a show that knows itself so well
and understands that it's not
about the case of the week,
it's about your favorite
people solving it.
And I think that's the secret sauce.
And you know, the fact that we're still
averaging 11 million a
week is unbelievable.
- [Kelly] That's incredible.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. So you also do
something called My Hour a Day.
What's that? I want this.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- What is this?
It feels like a good kind of selfish.
- I deserve this. Yes, I deserve this.
- Yeah.
- So, you know, and I know
you can relate to this, Kelly.
There was a time, excuse me,
there was a time in my life
where I just said, "What else can I do?
And how much more can I do?"
And I was traveling and shooting
multiple shows at the same time.
I remember at the time I was
shooting "Minority Report"
and "From Dusk Till Dawn"
and "Grey's Anatomy"
all in the same week.
And I was, I couldn't
even get on the freeway.
I had to helicopter from set to set
just to make these jobs possible.
And then, you know, and then
I had a production company
and I'm producing all
these things and whatever.
And I was just going from
Monday through Monday, you know,
and I realized I started
getting, you know,
whenever I had three days off,
that's when my body's like,
"You're out for three days".
You know?
- It like shuts down for you.
- [Wilmer] It shuts down for you.
- It's like, "Nope".
- [Wilmer] Yeah, that's it.
- Yeah.
- And I realized that there
was common denominator in there
that I wasn't getting enough rest,
that I wasn't allowing my
brain to reboot, to restart.
And I started thinking about my day.
I'm like, "Well, I'm running
out of hours in the day."
But that wasn't the excuse,
the excuse was that like I was, you know,
I wasn't dedicating some
time of the day to myself.
So I thought. "If I don't
have one hour in 24 hours
to dedicate to myself".
It could be reading a book,
it could be going for a walk,
it could be just sitting,
it could be a nap, you know?
Or it could be working out.
You know, once I implemented that,
I realize how much your
body really appreciates it
and even more critically, how
much your mind deserves it.
- Yeah.
- And so I created this thing,
this hashtag called My
Hour a Day and you know,
I tag it on to all my
workouts and all that.
And I've seen fans from around the world
jumping in and doing their
hashtag My Hour a Day.
And it's created this
smaller community of people
that have finally said, "Okay,
you know, what's the hurry?
You know, and can I sit
with myself for an hour
and really think about, you
know, what I really want?"
You know, and then distribute
the rest of your day
based on the things that are
the most important to you.
But the clarity only happens in that hour.
So in that hour, start
doing an inventory of my day
and thinking like, "Oh, do
I really have to do this?"
"Is that a job that I really should take?"
And if you don't have time
to make those decisions,
you will find yourself
working all the way through.
(Kelly laughing)
- Like the people upstairs that know
what my weekend was are
dying laughing right now.
- You're going through it? Yeah.
- I literally, this weekend I was like,
I took time off and like was like,
"Oh, I have too much going on."
And then I got right back in.
- [Wilmer] Yeah.
- And it's, yeah. And it's just not good.
It's like, 'cause you,
I think too, for creative people
and you said you have
production company, I do too.
You love to be involved.
You love to create, right?
- Yeah.
- But it's like you just
stretch yourself so thin
and we don't get it, there's like less,
I was saying this earlier,
literally in the glam room,
I was like, "There's less
days ahead of a lot for us
than behind, you know?"
- Right, right.
- So it's like, and we just don't know.
So it's like, how are we
choosing to, like use that time?
- [Wilmer] Yeah.
- And like having kids,
like, it's like you wanna
- And then you add you have to enjoy that.
- [Kelly] And you want to.
- You gotta enjoy being a parent.
You gotta enjoy being at home
because that's why you're
- And you don't enjoy going
"I know I'm not supposed to be
working on the weekend, honey
but they're calling me."
- Yeah.
- It's like, yeah.
- [Wilmer] Yeah.
- So it's a hard thing to do.
To implement.
- It's a hard thing to do.
And I'll tell you this, and
then for anybody at home who's,
or here who's actually
relating to this conversation.
It's not about like quitting things
or it's not about avoiding things,
it's about having an hour where you can,
you are loving the process of being
and doing something for yourself
and then allowing that to create clarity
in which there follows priority, right?
'Cause then the priority
will be something joyful.
Because if you're prioriting something,
then it basically tells
you that's the thing
that you wanna do, you know?
- Yeah.
But you don't, if you don't take the time
to even sift through that.
- You can't, you wouldn't
be able to do it.
- And then get stretched too
thin and you don't enjoy it.
- That's right.
- Says my past weekend.
(Kelly and Wilmer laughing)
Ha ha ha. (laughs)
You're you're a dad now
and your daughter just turned two.
(audience clapping)
- Yeah.
- This is so cool.
- That's my chookie.
That's my chookie chookie.
- I love the '70s party.
- Oh yeah.
You know, first year was "Encanto". Yeah.
- Oh my god, what a first.
- [Wilmer] Yeah.
- What a great first birthday.
- Her first year was "Encanto"
and we made her her own magical door too.
It was pretty cool.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- I wish I'd given you that picture.
Anyways, I snoozed on it.
- I like what I'm creating
in my head anyway.
I like, it's so magical.
You had a whole art team like in my head.
That's amazing though, the '70s thing.
Did you like, I don't know, bring out Fez?
Did you for this party?
- Well, what you saw me wearing there
was one of Fez's classic outfits.
- You still fit in it?
Screw you.
- Girl.
It's called my one hour a day.
- I can promise you my one hour a day
will not be working out. (laughs)
My one hour a day will look like this.
(Wilmer laughing)
Like, I just wanna sit.
I love that. The "Encanto"
birthday, that's so cool.
Wait, watch what's happening. (laughs)
- [Wilmer] It's a long story,
but if you guys go to my Instagram
I think you'll be,
you'll get more context.
- [Kelly] I am just very happy
for you that you fit in it.
That's incredible. Go you. Go you.